hi Georgie wake up okay what happened  you fainted okay  let me start over my name is Largey I  was used to being invisible no one was  paying attention to what I was doing I  read a letter when I have a crush so  intense that I don't know what else to  do there are five total Peter with the  beautiful eyes Kenny from Camp Lucas  from homecoming John Andrews from Model  UN and Josh the boy next door  [Music]  Hey what are you doing nothing nobody  else knows about them can you maybe just  admit that some part of you doesn't want  everything in your life to be a fantasy  you've got to get out there and show  people who you really are  Largey yourself  [Music]  let's do this  hey can I talk to you  me yeah look I really I appreciate it  but it's never gonna happen I'm sorry  what I think it's really cool that you  think I have Colden specs in my eyes oh  my god  the letters are out  [Music]